muy buenos días raúl pues pensilvania
sigue contando votos a contrarreloj
quedan todavía cerca de un millón de
papeletas por abrir y lo hacen con una
gran presión sobre sus hombros y más
después de que ayer familiares de donald
trump y el abogado personal del
presidente rudy giuliani viajarán hasta
pensilvania para detener el recuento de
votos alegando según ello es un supuesto
fraude pensilvania ya dijo que los
resultados finales podrían no saberse
hasta el viernes por esa avalancha
histórica de votos por correo que han
recibido en estos momentos el presidente
de donald trump lleva una ventaja de dos
escasos puntos y según las reglas del
estado si la diferencia entre entre los
resultados es de tan sólo 05 puntos
los candidatos podrían pedir un recuento
automático de estos votos
mamen hablemos ahora de los otros dos
estados de la costa este que están por
definir
hablamos de georgia y carolina del norte
dos estados clave también raúl donde
donald trump lleva también una muy
ajustada ventaja estos dos estados han
sido tradicionalmente republicanos aquí
se está dando en los dos el mismo
fenómeno las grandes urbes están
apostando por el demócrata joe biden
mientras que los votos de donald trump
están llegando de los suburbios en
carolina del norte ha sido republicano
las diez últimas elecciones hasta que
llegó barack obama por lo que los
demócratas tienen gran esperanza en este
estado por la parte de georgia ocurre
algo muy parecido el único demócrata en
los últimos años que hemos visto allí ha
sido bill clinton
y en este momento la cosa está también
muy ajustada a estos resultados están
también muy ajustados y podríamos decir
que va a ir en cuenta con un apoyo
importante el de la población
afroamericana que representa un 50 por
ciento de la población cuenta también
con un bastión demócrata importante en
georgia que es atlanta a la ciudad de
atlanta y sobre todo y más importante
con ese voto por correo que todavía se
sigue contando y que al parecer la grama
está registrada como demócrata así que
habrá que esperar porque todo puede
cambiar